- [Narrator] The heart pumps
blood throughout the body.
Carrying oxygen and
nutrients to every cell.
It's this circulation
of blood that is vital
to sustaining life.
The heart is an organ made up of several
tough layers of muscle.
The pericardium is the thin
layer that covers the exterior
while the endocardium
lines the inside walls.
The heart is divided into four chambers.
Two upper and two lower.
The upper chambers known
as the atrium receive blood
coming into the heart.
The lower chambers are the
ventricles that pump blood out.
Between each chamber are
valves that open and close
and help keep the blood moving.
They are the tricuspid, mitral,
pulmonary, and aortic valves.
A pumping cycle starts
when oxygen repleted blood
returns to the heart after
circulating throughout the body.
The blood enters through the
right atrium before flowing
to the right ventricle.
It's then pumped to the lungs
via the pulmonary arteries.
There blood is rejuvenated
by air that's breathed in.
The oxygen rich blood
returns to the heart through
the left atrium where it
goes to the left ventricle.
Then by way of the aorta artery
the fresh blood is pumped
throughout the body before
the process repeats itself.
That process happens with every heartbeat.
And it's relentless.
The heart beats 100,000 times a day.
40 million times a year
and up to three billion times
over an average lifespan.
But there are conditions
that can disrupt a heartbeat
and that normality.
They can range from myocardial
infarction or heart attack
to heart disease and hypertension.
In contrast, exercise
and emotional excitement
can also have an impact
on a person's heartbeat.
The various blood vessels that comprise
the circulatory system are a
network of veins, arteries,
and capillaries that
span over 60,000 miles
throughout the body.
And the heart is the
pump at the center of it.
(heartbeat)